Prof: You may recall
that last time we went over the
shape of Dante's cosmos,
remember.
And the point there,
one of the points was to show
that the context of Dante's
experience,
the way he moves,
the tale he's telling about
this extraordinary experience he
has,
is really the whole cosmos.
It's not just one's own town,
one's own place and so on,
it really takes place within
the cosmos and we saw how Dante
describes that cosmos.
He describes it in terms of a
physical and a metaphysical
principle.
That is to say,
all the materiality and the
spirituality of two hemispheres
all placed in one.
The Empyrean is the threshold
and the limit of the physical
cosmos and the way of entering
into the spiritual cosmos.
The challenge he has as a poet
is that to show the relationship
between the finite and the
infinite,
the way that they are really
disjointed and at the same time
they are not.
The finite universe can only be
part of the infinite universe
and so he describes how the
infinite enters the finite and
the finite enters the infinite.
This is heart of the cantos of
metaphysics which we all
call--which we can call the
cantos of physics and
metaphysics at the same time.
Now, Dante moves straight into
the Empyrean,
he was in the--you remember
into the primo mobile or
the crystalline heaven,
before that he was in the
Heaven of the Fixed Stars XXV,
XXVI, XXVII then he moved into
the crystalline;
now he is into the Empyrean.
This is the end of the race for
him;
it's the end of the journey.
The question will be how he is
going to say farewell to
Beatrice.
There will be a change of the
guard.
Beatrice--the role of Beatrice
as a guide will stop,
will end with Canto XXX of
Paradise,
quite appropriately;
it's suitable;
she is the woman tied with the
number 30.
She appeared in Canto XXX of
Purgatorio,
stays on the stage of the poem
for thirty three cantos and now
she's going to actually
disappear.
He'll realize that she has
disappeared in Canto XXXI.
But there's a change of the
guard because Dante moves from
Beatrice to a contemplative,
a historical figure all the
time, almost all the time with
Dante,
Bernard of Clairvaux,
who was a famous monk of--
French monk who stands for--he
has written treatises on
contemplation and mystical
visions.
So appropriately,
he's the one who will usher and
pray the Virgin Mary that she
may in turn pray her son,
it's a chain of mediations so
that the beatific vision may be
granted to Dante.
That's going to happen with
Canto XXX and we are going to
find out the difficulties that
Dante has in both seeing,
but above all,
in recalling and recollecting.
The poem will end up with being
a sort of registering the
defeat, the unavoidable defeat
of memory and importance of
forgetfulness.
We are going to find in Canto
XXXIII a sort of further twist
to the metaphor of--
you remember in Canto XXXIII of
Purgatorio that I
mentioned to you what has
happening.
Dante will go on being immersed
ritually into the River Lethe
and then into River Eunoe.
There are two rivers,
one the river of forgetfulness,
the one the river of memory,
of good memory and Dante goes
on saying that they really
came--
he was at the point where the
two streams were really
originating from the same
source.
It as if memory and
forgetfulness--first of all,
I equate it with water there in
Canto XXXIII of
Purgatorio implying the
lability,
the water has that quality of
flowing,
the fluidity,
the ability of both memory and
forgetfulness.
The most important thing is
that they originated from the
same place.
It is as if Dante were already
preparing what will move now
front stage in Paradiso
XXXIII,
namely the notion of a
forgetful memory,
and the importance of forgetful
memory,
you have to forget and you have
to remember and somehow the two
are going to be brought
together.
It's not a mystical proposition
that he advances;
it's actually the way of
justifying his poem and we'll
come to that in some detail
in--when we come to Canto
XXXIII.
What I would emphasize,
though, to move now to Canto
XXX, Dante's entering into the
Heavenly Jerusalem which is a
garden and it's a city.
It will be described as such,
you will see in--
well, let's turn right now to
these images--
this is really Canto XXX
line--a sequence of images lines
32-- I'm sorry 110 and
following, page 437,
"I saw," line 112,
"I saw,
rising above the light all
around in more than a thousand
tiers,
as many of us as have returned
there above."
The Heavenly Jerusalem is first
of all described as a theatre
and we ought to really think
about it for a moment,
a theatre.
"And if the lowest
rank," that's the image of
theatre where you have in an
auditorium today,
tiers, "encloses within it
so great a light,
what is the expense of this
rose in its farthest
petals?"
The second image is that it's
described--to describe this--the
Heavenly Jerusalem is the rose,
a white rose,
a mystical rose.
I can tell you immediately that
Dante is using the image that
this is--
it derives straight out of
thirteenth-century French poem
called,
The Romance of the Rose,
which Dante had translated as a
young man into a sequence of
sonnets,
part of his experimenting with
poetic forms.
But it's also--it's deeply
altered because The Romance
of the Rose,
which is an extraordinary
satirical poem,
it's a compendium of all
knowledge,
it really has--it deals
with--it's a story of--
about nature and about reason.
The connections between reason
and nature but it's also a story
with a sexual theme.
Dante is clearly taking that
language of The Romance of
the Rose and literally
spiritualizing,
reversing it.
The resonances of the original
poem are still there so that you
are forced to think of the
Heavenly Jerusalem as also
having some kind of materiality
within it,
so you cannot just say,
well I'm taking that image,
placing it in a different
context, and hope that the
original,
the residues,
the traces of that original
image are going to be completely
faced.
It's part of the strategy of,
once again hinting,
intimating that spirituality
and materiality now are still
going to be converging here.
That's the archaeology,
let's say, of this image of the
rose.
This continues,
next paragraph,
"Into the yellow of the
eternal rose,
which expends and rises in
ranks, and exhales odours of
praise to the Sun that makes
perpetual spring,
Beatrice drew me,
as one who is silent and fain
would speak,
and she said:
'Behold how great is the
assembly of the white
robes!'"
This is a procession,
a theatrical performance of
sorts, the whole of paradise is
a theatrical performance,
and whenever we think of
theatre--now,
let me just reflect a little
bit on this image.
Whenever we think of a theatre,
we understand that it implies
the reduction of the world to a
spectacle, that's what a theatre
is.
The world is something to be
seen, it's also an optical
phenomenon,
or a case, to put it in another
way,
which really does not do any
violence on the text,
a question of the
representation.
The world is a representation
implying that I become the
spectator.
I am--it's their representation
for me,
I can really watch this world,
and see it in its whole
totality just as Dante is seeing
the whole of the universe,
now he can see the whole
totality of the blessed.
This is the whole of the
Heavenly Jerusalem where all the
blessed will be sitting,
enjoying, acting,
and spectating at the same
time.
Two or three things that I want
to say here;
on the one hand,
the theatre is an image of
multiple perspectives,
that's what a theatre implies.
You are sitting there,
I'm standing here,
multiple perspectives but Dante
wants to say that he's enjoying
an overall perspective,
what we call a perspective of
the whole.
He can see the whole of reality.
He sees the whole expanse of
the horizon of the world.
In other words,
whatever he's saying about
himself, it partakes of and it
belongs to the totality of the
world.
He's not seeing something
isolated or disconnected with
the rest of the world.
This is, to him,
what legitimizes a claim to be
a visionary poet.
To be truly a visionary poet,
you have to be able to see the
whole of a reality,
not just like Narcissus your
own image,
not like someone who is bound
to one's own perspective,
one's own self.
He sees the whole of the world
and that's really what I think
is the claim or the implications
of the image of the theatre.
The text, I think need some
glossing, "Behold how great
is the assembly of the white
robes."
A sense of the magnitude of the
spectacle;
then, "See our city,
how great it is,
its circuit."
It has been described a littler
earlier as--in terms of a rose
and a garden,
and now it's a city,
that's an interesting shift in
Dante's poem.
It's an interesting shift for a
number of reasons because the
whole poem now appears as
literally a journey from the
wilderness,
not to the garden,
but to a city or to a garden
which is a city.
It is a way of encompassing the
whole movement of the poem
within these two figures.
This is--it is as if the whole
impulse behind this experience
of Dante is a reintegration into
what is it he implies.
The place where many other
people are as if--
I not only seeing the world as
a whole,
I want to be part of this
whole, and the way of being part
of this whole is this political
poem.
This city, heavenly city to be
sure,
but it has--the idea of city
always implies some human
contact,
some human idea of what we call
usually the polis,
the political reality.
Let me just add something else
which is interesting in terms of
Dante's imagination.
We have a compression of images
from the pastoral tradition.
The garden and the idea of
city, and we do know that when
you read pastoral literature you
really have,
usually have this
juxtaposition,
it's called,
between the urbs which you know
is--
the term's for the urban now
for the city from the
rus,
the rustic, a division between
gardens and cities.
This is the economy on which
pastoral literature,
eclogues, bucolic,
ideals, idyllic literature is
usually based on,
on this divergence between the
two modes of the imagination.
I live in the city and then I
want to go down into the villa.
I want to go down to the
country;
it's as if there were two--a
kind of--almost a hint of a
schizophrenic existence that you
have with Roman and Greek
poetry.
What Dante's doing is literally
shattering that distance between
the two modes.
In an eschatological
perspective, in a perspective
which is at the end,
city and garden come together.
It is literally a change,
both in the idea of the city
and in the idea of the garden.
They are not two divergent
modes of the imaginatio;
they really cohere within one.
You see what the point is.
The point is that no matter
what Dante is touching with his
imagination,
all the oppositions,
all systems of contrarieties,
of contrary forms,
he tries to always bring them
together in a kind of
concordance,
discordant made concordant
again, which is the idea of
music.
A kind of a harmonization of
all these oppositions and
everything that he has--we so
far have been seeing.
But now there is a further
image which sort of complicates
the problem.
"'See our seats so filled
that few souls are now wanting
there.'"
This is a kind of line which is
really strange because it's
implying that for all of us late
comers there is no room,
there is not even standing room
there for us--
the places have all been taken,
almost all been taken.
Very few, the implication is,
are going to be saved.
Then one can make this claim,
it follows, because he really
believes that this is a kind
of--that he has what we can an
apocalyptic vision.
That the end of the world is
near, therefore,
he can say only a few seats are
available,
or which is really the way I
think,
because I don't think that
Dante really has an apocalyptic
vision.
That is to say,
what I mean by an apocalyptic
vision,
apocalypse means visionary,
he is a visionary,
apocalyptic means,
implies the imminence of the
ending of history.
I don't think that he has that
idea at all.
A man who keeps thinking as he
does about the renewal or the
corruption of institutions,
the hope that some intervention
will come from other human
beings or from--
of history, a king for
instance, or an intervention
from the world of grace,
cannot really have a sense of
the imminent consummation of
history.
You see what I mean?
You wouldn't be worried so much
about renewing the institutions.
This line is to--can be taken
to mean,
and I think has to be taken to
mean,
is that scene from the
perspective of eternity as he is
really there are a few seats.
You see what I'm saying?
If you see it in terms of the
totality of time then they are
not--a lot of time has been--has
already passed by.
Then he will continue--a
haunting image I think that sort
of gives all this talk of this--
my reflections on city,
whether Dante has an
apocalyptic imagination or not
an apocalyptic imagination,
look at how this absence,
"And in that great chair
on which thy eyes are held by
the crown that is already set
over it,"
an empty seat,
it's taken, a crown is on it,
a king is going to be sitting,
that's what I call a haunting
image of royal absence and royal
presence because you'll see in a
moment what it is.
"Before thou shalt sup at
these nuptials shall rest the
soul, which shall be imperial
below, of lofty Henry."
This is the emperor who
actually died in 1313 whom Dante
was hoping would come down to
Italy from the Holy Roman
Empire;
come down to Italy to set Italy
straight.
That is to say,
to placate the violence between
the cities,
the whole history of Italian
communes,
but he had died prematurely and
he's expected in heaven.
You see there is a way in which
the king,
the emperor is beatified,
his seat in heaven is going to
be assured,
and yet implying that somehow
the violence in history is going
to be,
for the time being,
continued and prolonged,
so a political interest,
a political--
the keeping,
the holding on to Dante's own
fantasies of political renewals
that gives therefore the sort
of--
that tempers all views that
Dante may have,
an apocalyptic imagination.
"The blind greed that
bewitches you has made you like
the infant,"
etc., and then Dante goes on,
the other great problem.
The canto ends with a final
denunciation about Simon Magus
and the reference to
Inferno XIX.
Dante's at the height of the
universe,
he can't forget Simon Magus,
Inferno XIX,
and Boniface XVIII,
"gets his dues,
and shall make him of Anagni
go," Boniface XVIII,
"deeper still."
Remember how they were punished
being upside down in the
ditches,
and the flames of fire,
Pentecostal flames of fire,
on the soles of their feet,
this is the way they have been
twisting around,
turning around the gift of
prophecy.
Let me just go onto Canto XXXI;
it's really a farewell to
Beatrice, and I thought that we
expected so much her arrival in
Canto XXX of Purgatorio;
we should see how the farewell
takes place.
Canto XXXI, lines 40 and
following,
page 449, "I who had come
to the divine from the
human," this is Dante
speaking for himself,
"to the eternal from time,
and from Florence to a people
just and sane,
with what amazement must I have
been filled!
Truly between that and the joy
I was content to hear nothing
and to remain silent.
And like a pilgrim who is
refreshed in the temple of his
vow as he looks around and hopes
sometime to tell of it again,
so, taking my way up through
the living light,
I carried my eyes through the
ranks,
now up, now down,"
he looks around to see whom he
sees and he actually will go on
listing the number of blessed,
the women and men that he sees.
"I carried my eyes through
the ranks, now up,
now down and now looking round
again.
I saw faces,
persuasive to charity,"
used to charity,
"adorned with Another's
light,
and with their own smiles."
These blessed are blessed
because they are--there's some
other in them.
They are themselves and there
is another in them too,
"and with their own
smiles, and every movement
graced with dignity.
Already my glance had taken in
the whole general form of
Paradise,"
what I called earlier,
the vision of the whole,
the totality that he manages
to-- gazes at.
"But had not yet dwelt on
any part of it,
and I turned with new-kindled
eagerness to question my Lady of
things in which my mind was in
suspense."
We have now a revision,
a rehashing,
if you wish,
of the scene of Virgil's
disappearance when Beatrice is
just about to come.
Dante saw all stricken by and
seized by tremor at the
approaching of Beatrice that he
turns around to try to see and
get comfort from Virgil and
Virgil had vanished.
We have now a kind of variant
of that same vanishing act.
"One thing I intended,
and another encountered me:
I thought to see Beatrice,
and I saw an old man,"
Bernard of Clairvaux,
the great enemy of the
so-called of the philosophers,
but I don't want to get into
that.
"clothed like that
glorious company.
His eyes and his cheeks were
suffused with a gracious
gladness, and his aspect was of
such kindness as befits a tender
father.
And 'Where is she?'
I said in haste;
and he replied:
'To end thy longing Beatrice
sent me from my place;
and if thou look up to the
third circle from the highest
tier thou shall see her again,
in the throne her merits have
assigned to her.'
Without answering,
I lifted up my eyes and saw her
where she made for herself a
crown, reflecting from her the
eternal beams.
From the highest region where
it thunders no mortal eye is so
far, were it lost in the depth
of the sea, was my sight there
from Beatrice;
but to me it made no
difference, for her image came
down to me undimmed by aught
between.
'O Lady,"
here he goes on now,
"in whom my hope has its
strength and who didst bear for
my salvation to leave thy
footprints in Hell,
of all the things that I have
seen I acknowledge the grace and
the virtue to be from that power
and from thy goodness.
It is thou who hast drawn me
from bondage into liberty."
The great theme of liberty that
we have been discussing,
especially in Purgatory
found also--it's sealed here in
the presence of Beatrice,
etc.
This is now--he turns to the
faithful Bernard.
You may remember that Canto
XXIX ended with Beatrice very
worried that Dante has been
expounding.
Remember Canto XXVIII,
XXIX there had been the
exposition about angels,
the exposition about creation,
creation as an act of God's
love,
the ordering and the new ranks
of angelic-- the angelic choir.
Then Beatrice gets very upset
because the whole issue seemed
to be to her a way of thinking
more about the appearance of
things rather than the truth of
things.
You remember that she attacks
the human beings on Earth;
they do nothing else than go
after false appearances.
We are swayed by false
appearances so that the question
was, what does she mean that the
truth is?
She was saying let's get back
to some--
let's bring some kind of sense
of the real back into play in
all of this,
some sense of the truth value
what we are saying back into
this representation.
That was the way Canto XXIX
stopped, with Beatrice
suspicious of appearances.
Dante now gets into Canto XXX
and XXXI and goes back to the
question of appearances,
and says to Beatrice that the
appearance is exactly what--
the image is exactly what he
has preserved,
that he is going to preserve of
her.
Two things, therefore,
have to be followed from this.
Are you with me in all of these
issues?
Dante's saying here,
in the encounter with Beatrice,
"Without answering,
I lifted my eyes and saw her
where she made herself a crown,
reflecting from her the eternal
beams."
This is the language of image
and the language of reflections.
What Dante's saying to Beatrice
is that we are always in a world
of images,
and that somehow the image is
the locus of the sacredness,
but the image is also has its
own fleeting quality.
The journey of Dante is to go
between the images and the
essences.
Now he's preparing for the
final leap.
This is to say that Dante's
journey was not a journey to
Beatrice;
it's going to be a journey to
God.
Beatrice is the stepping stone
for the pilgrim's entering the
experience of the beatific
vision.
This is what I want to
emphasize, and in fact,
Canto XXXI, ends with,
"Like one that
comes," line 113,
"Like one that comes,
perhaps, from Croatia,
to see our Veronica,"
Veronica is an allusion to one
of the pious women,
who during the Calvary ascent
of Jesus,
is said to have wiped his face
and the face of Jesus remained
imprinted on her veil and so
that Veronica became--
it's the name of the woman
Veronica,
but it was also understood in
the whole of Middle Ages as
vera icona,
this was the kind of phony,
to be sure etymology given to
the Veronica.
It was--Dante's evoking now the
pilgrims who come to--who go to
Rome from Croatia to see the
true image left imprinted on the
veil of the Veronica.
This is where Dante himself is.
He is like one of those
pilgrims who is still seeing the
image but wants to move beyond
images, wants to go and see what
lies behind it.
The journey of the Divine
Comedy is the journey within
that in tercets,
between images and essences so
to speak.
This is Veronica,
"and whose old hunger is
never satisfied,
but he says within himself,
as long as it is shown:
'My Lord Jesus Christ,
very God, was this then your
true semblance?',
such was I, gazing on the
living charity of him who in
this world tasted by
contemplation of the
peace."
That's how we can--we are ready
to get into Canto XXXIII which
is the final canto and the final
vision.
Let's see how Dante carries
that off and let me begin with
saying a couple of things.
There are a number of dramas
that will go--are going to be
unfolding in Canto XXXIII.
The first drama is that of the
pilgrim who wants to see the
face of God,
wants to see the face of God,
wants to preserve the wit so
that he can be able to come back
and retell the story,
tell the story,
write the poem as a witnessing
to the vision he has had.
So it's a way of thinking about
the relationship between vision
and language,
if you want to say it in a very
general way.
How are the two related to each
other?
The real--the other drama is
how is he going to remember?
Can he remember?
Number four,
what does he really see?
These are the number of
problems that he faces.
The poem begins with--Canto
XXXIII begins with a prayer,
a prayer to the Virgin Mary,
or the Virgin Mother,
and it's going to be
constructed through a series of
paradoxes as you can see,
Virgin Mother,
daughter of your son,
paradox is about time,
paradox is about all sorts of
reversals of the natural order,
"lowly and exalted more
than any creature,"
a way of using paradoxes that
challenge the rational
understanding of the world.
This is not going to be a
rational representation of what
Dante will see,
"fixed goal of the eternal
council,
thou art she who didst so
ennoble human nature,
that its Maker did not disdain
to be made its making.
In thy womb,"
Dante goes on now to that motif
of birth with which we began
talking from Inferno I,
when we discussed Virgil.
This idea of the beginning,
the idea of a beginning of
birth as an image of beginning,
and an image of nature becoming
an event;
the idea of nature becoming a
historical event,
a possibility of a historical
event.
"In thy womb was rekindled
the love by whose warmth this
flower,"
this flower really means the
whole of the mystical rose that
he has just seen,
so the mystical rose begins
in--it's contained in the womb
of Mary,
"has bloomed thus in the
eternal peace."
It's another way of making this
idea of--
I could gloss this image of the
womb as--
in terms of this is the immense
sphere of the mystic,
within which--the immense
sphere within which the finite
and the infinite come together
and meet.
The immense sphere,
it's a circle;
the immense sphere whose center
is nowhere, or whose center is
everywhere, whose circumference
is nowhere.
That's the way that he is
understanding,
he's explaining this motif of
the incarnation.
What is crucial about this
image, I believe,
is first of all,
the humanization of the divine.
This is clearly the divine that
becomes divine because it enters
history and experiences all that
the human beings experience.
The other element that,
I think, that Dante is pushing
forth is the feminization of the
divine in the sense that here
the divine has become the child
of a woman,
and the woman is therefore
part, they subsume this part of
this divine.
A kind of feminine--I don't
call it feminist because I don't
really know what that is but the
feminine--
and I don't mean it as in--it's
a true statement I don't know,
but it's a feminine,
a theology of a feminine
element in God.
"Here thou art for us the
noonday torch of charity,
and below among mortals thou
art living spring of hope."
And then the second stylistic
theme here is the repetition,
the iterative mode,
"Thou, Lady,"
skip a few lines,
and "Thy loving-kindness
in thee is mercy,
in thee pity,
in thee great bounty,
in thee is joined all goodness
there in any creature."
What is the point of this
iterativeness of--the style of
repetitions of anaphoric style?
I think one of the reasons,
you may think of others,
but one of the reasons is a
language that is falling upon
itself as a way of giving
consistency to itself.
The poem at this point is
really dealing with vanishing
traces,
things that cannot quite be
pinpointed or placed within
logical propositions,
and therefore,
the language becomes
incantatory as if it were an
effort to create a kind of--
a mood, a sort of--creating a
reality through this mood
induced through these
iterations.
Then the prayer of Bernard
continues,
"This man,"
and in the pilgrim line 30,
20, "This man,
who from the nethermost pit of
the universe to here has seen
one by one the lives of the
spirits,
now begs of thee by thy grace
for such power that with his
eyes he may rise still higher
towards the last salvation;
and I,"
this is extraordinary.
We are in Paradise,
so far,
Dante strays so far from the
temptations of mystical writing,
which ends up always evoking
identities,
representable identities;
Dante distinguishes very
carefully until the end between
I and he.
There are individualities in
this Paradise of Dante's
imagination,
"And I,"
this is Bernard,
"who never burned from my
own vision more than I do for
his."
See the differences,
I and him, "offer to thee
all my prayers,
and pray that they come not
short, that by thy prayers thy
wilt disperse for him every
cloud of his mortality so that
the supreme joy may be disclosed
to him."
That's the first prayer to the
Virgin.
"This too I pray to thee,
Queen, who canst what thou
wilt, that thou keep his
affections pure after so great a
vision."
The first danger to the pilgrim
is that he may be losing
literally his mind.
The vision of God may--a face
may obliterate his powers
of--this vision may obliterate
the powers and the affections.
"Let thy guardianship
control his human impulses.
See Beatrice and so many of the
blessed who clasp their hands
for my prayers."
This is an extraordinary vision.
The whole of the cosmos is
praying for Dante--the pilgrim's
beatific visions.
"The eyes by God beloved
and reverenced…
and I, who was drawing near to
the end of all desires."
I want to emphasize this,
even this language of desire,
up to know the poem has
been--can be called literally--
we've been calling it so many
things,
a poem of hope,
a poem of peace,
it's a poem of exile,
and poem of desire and the poem
of longing.
The prayer is the mode of this
longing.
Prayer, you address someone you
don't see hoping that you can be
heard and that your prayer can
be answered is a desire for a
response.
This is really the mode of
Dante's theology.
At the heart of his theological
universe, there is a sense of
constant longing and a sense of
being not quite where he wants
to be.
"I who was drawing near to
the end of all desires,"
I emphasize and I prepare you
in case I would not make a point
about that.
Very soon the language of Dante
will change from desire to
enjoyment.
He starts getting the sense of
this sweetness and this idea of
the fullness of his pleasures.
A desire will shift into joy
very soon, "ended perforce
the ardour of my craving.
Bernard signed to me with a
smile to look upward,
but already of myself I was
doing what he wished;
for my sight,
becoming pure,
was entering more and more
through the beam of the lofty
light which in itself is
true."
Now the first defeat;
Dante starts recording the
forgetfulness of this
experience.
"From that moment,"
first of all,
"my vision was greater
than our speech,
which fails at such a
sight."
How are you going to make a
failure become a success?
How--from the fact that he is
not going to be able to see will
become somehow a mode of his
own,
not just a humility because it
would be a success in terms of
the pilgrim's own humility,
but in terms of the writing of
the poem.
Now the poem will be a
different way of understanding
the poem,
not just going to be a
representation of plentitude of
vision,
but until the end the statement
of a longing for a vision that
may come.
The memory too fails to such
excess.
Excess in Italian is really the
language--I don't know,
probably English is best,
etymologically it's the same
thing, but in Italian it's
outrage.
Outrage in the sense in which
with resonance that there is
something too bold and over--
a kind of hyperbolic,
an overreaching because that's
really what it is.
An excess is an overreaching,
"Like him that sees in a
dream and after the dream the
passion wrought by it remains
and the rest returns not to his
mind, such am I;
for my vision almost wholly
fades, and still there drops
within my heart the sweetness
that was born from it."
That's all he's going to be
left with.
This sweetness that gathers in
the chamber of the heart.
This has been a journey of the
heart,
because as I have been saying
to you in a number of ways in
the past few weeks,
is that the journey to God is a
journey of the mind,
but it's a journey of the heart.
You have to--you will come to
know God through this idea of
the heart.
But also, you know,
that Dante's clearly punning on
the notion of what memory is,
because to him memory is
connecting to those with a
heart.
What can I remember?
What can I recall within me?
What is this--the only thing
that memory can retrieve is this
sweetness of the heart.
Such a--then he continues,
"Thus the snow loses its
imprint in the sun."
The image of the liquefaction
of shapes,
the loss of shapes,
water that had been
crystallized just dissolves,
and then an image which brings
us back to the Aeneid,
the third book of the
Aeneid,
"thus in the wind on the
light leaves the Sybil's oracle
was lost."
This is the idea when Aeneas
goes to the Sybil's cave to find
out about the future,
his future, and as the Sybil
opens the gates the wind comes
and will go on scattering all
the leaves kept within it.
It's the impossibility of
reading,
the impossibility of
deciphering the actual leaves,
like sort of messiness and
confusion,
that's exactly the state of
mind in which he seems to find
himself.
"O Light Supreme,"
Dante now shifts to another
mode on his own,
and now in a sequence of
prayers.
"O Light Supreme that art
so far exalted above mortal
conceiving,
grant to my mind again a little
of what thou appearedst,
and give my tongue,"
this is the kind of--
the prayer of--this is the
prayer of that language may,
I am missing a page here--this
is the prayer that somehow,
language now may triumph over
him, over the threats of
forgetfulness.
Forgetfulness threatens him.
Why am I insisting so much?
"That it may leave but a
gleam of thy glory to the people
yet to come."
What Dante is saying is that
his poem is meant for the
future, that in effect,
he's envisioning a future.
This is not a poem written for
him, it's not a poem written for
his contemporaries,
it's a positing of a future.
That is to say,
the opening up to,
and that's what work will do,
a work of art invents and
prepares a future,
so more than an act of
remembrance,
and the commemoration,
the poem will be what we call
it,
a prolepsis,
a proleptic move,
a movement forward into the
future.
Why do I talk so much about
memory?
Dante seems to be becoming now
utopian,
lend me some of your glory,
let me see your glory so that a
spark of it may be left in my
text,
so that the future will
understand it and will see,
and some fire can come from
that spark.
Now why does then language--his
insistence on memory?
Because that's the answer,
he talks about retrieving the
memory of what he has seen
because the actual constitution
of his poem,
he can only his write his poem,
he can only have some authority
for his voice if he remembers
what he has seen.
In order to ground the poem in
the notion into the vision of
God,
that therefore,
will authorize him to say all
of the things he has been saying
about the living and the dead,
the powerful and the not so
powerful,
the historical figures and the
cultural figures of the past,
it's crucial for him to
remember so that memory becomes
the actual foundation of his
representation.
He has to bring it back,
give it a presence to what has
gone on in his experience.
Do you see what I mean?
He's forced to go on
remembering and yet he cannot.
How is he going to--where does
his authority come from then?
If he can't remember,
and he says that he can
remember very little,
only the sweetness that has
been gathering in his heart,
where does it come from?
This is the third--fourth
challenge of the poem.
"I think,"
he continues,
"from the keenness I
endured of the living ray,
that I should have been dazzled
if my eyes had been turned from
it;
and I remember that for this
cause I was the bolder to
sustain it until I reached with
my gaze the Infinite
Goodness."
Once again, breaking the
narrative and turning into the
meditative, a prayer,
sort of begging that the divine
may reveal itself and remain
with him.
"O abounding grace,
by which I dared to fix my look
on the Eternal Light so long
that I spent all my sight upon
it.
In its depth."
That's what he sees.
"I saw that it
contained,"
the cosmos as a book.
That's it, the whole world I
called it last time,
a cosmos book,
the cosmos as a book.
That is to say,
as a parchment maybe,
but he uses also the image of a
book which is different from a
volume, the volume is rolled up.
The book is the one which we
have a kind of square structure.
The two together,
as a kind of allegory wrapped
up.
"I think I saw…
in its depth I saw that it
contained,
bound by love in one
volume,"
now that was the word Dante had
used for Virgil at the beginning
of the poem.
A way to give continuity to his
quest and his questions begins
with the volume of Virgil's book
and that Virgil's book becomes a
pre-figuration of the book of
the cosmos that he sees bound
together.
"That which is scattered
in leaves through the universe,
substances and accidents and
their relations as it were fused
together in such a way that what
I tell of it is a simple light.
I think I saw the universal
form of this complex,"
of this compound,
"because in telling of it
I feel my joy expand."
Now is the retrieval of--or
rather the recovery of this
state of mind,
which is one of joy,
which excludes absence.
Desire has to be replaced by
joy because desire always
entails an absence.
We long for what we do not
have, at least at that moment.
Desire is always tied to an
experience of lacking.
Joy is tied to an experience of
plentitude of a procession
somehow at this point,
and now another mythological
figure that I want to focus on.
"A single moment makes for
me deeper oblivion,"
you see now the dialectics
between memory that fails and
oblivion does its memory,
and efforts at remembering and
the reality of forgetfulness.
This was the dialectic between
the two metaphors together,
"A single moment makes for
me deeper oblivion than five and
twenty centuries upon the
enterprise that made Neptune
wonder at the shadow of the
Argo."
What an extraordinary image.
Single moment,
it's clearly an image to say
that I forgot more in one
second, so time doesn't exist
here.
It exists in Dante,
Dante is still being human,
he stills has time,
time is--at least he can only--
his life can only be measured
by time,
but he's in the presence of the
eternal instant,
but a single instant he says
literally,
I'm just glossing this,
a single instance made me
forget more than what we have
forgotten in twenty-five
centuries from the experience of
the Argo,
allusion to the Argonauts,
another mythological counter to
Dante's own journey.
They went for the--Jason went
for the golden fleece,
Dante's going for the beatific
vision,
another little connection to
Canto I of Paradiso
starts with a reference to the
story of the Argonauts,
the daring of the Argonauts,
and now Dante is closing the
circle here once again.
There's a further--something
else that in the story of the
Argonauts as Dante retrieves it,
is that the guard is now below,
Neptune is in the depth,
and Dante is now thinking of
the divine as being also caught
in its own unreachable,
unfathomable depth,
which is a height,
but you see there are two
different perspectives.
More importantly,
here Dante sees Neptune
wondering at the daring of man,
just as Neptune is wondering at
the daring of the Argonauts;
the implication is that he too
has had this kind of daring that
the divine, that God may be
wondering at his own
achievement.
What is crucial is the change
of perspective from the depth of
underneath the sea to the depth
up in the sky,
up in the heavens for Dante's
God.
Then he continues,
"Thus my mind,"
Dante's so careful--I wish we
had time about this to show you.
I mean I know that there are
some graduate students who may
want to think about this whole
issue of how Dante's lexicon
about mind,
intellect, reason,
he's so carefully calibrated
and differentiated;
mind is the faculty of
visionariness.
It's also the root word of
measure, as you know;
Latin etymology is--the
medieval minds are always taken
with the discovery of the root
words.
The word measure comes from the
immense, for instance,
comes from the word for mind.
It is as if he's still keeping
a sense of the measure for
himself.
He's still aware of his own
particular city.
He's not lost in the immensity
of what's around him,
"Thus my mind, all rapt,
was gazing, fixed still and
intent,
and ever enkindled with gazing.
At that light one becomes such
that it is impossible for him
ever to consent that he should
turn from it to another sight;
for the good which is the
object of the will is all
gathered in it,
and apart from it that is
defective which there is
perfect."
Now language fails,
memory fails;
the second failure is that of
speech.
"Now my speech will come
more short even or what I
remember than an infant's."
You know that the word infant,
which usually we take that to
be a child, it literally means
the child who cannot speak.
You refer;
you use the word infant for
someone who is pre-,
as it were babbling even,
that's the infant really.
"Fari,"
in Latin means to speak,
"And infant's who yet
bathes his tongue at the breast.
Not that the living light at
which I gazed had more than a
single aspect--
for it is ever the same as it
was before--
but that my sight gaining
strength as I looked,
the one sole appearance,
I myself changing was,
for me, transformed.
In the profound and clear
ground of the lofty light
appeared to me,"
that's the vision that he has,
"three circles of three
colours and the same extent,
and the one seemed reflected by
the other as rainbow by rainbow,
and the third seemed fire
breathed forth equally from the
one and the other.
O how scant is speech and how
feeble to my conception!"
It ends with an unavoidable
statement of failure,
a failure of memory so that the
memory can be forgetful memory,
and the failure of speech
unable to contain the plentitude
of what he sees.
Vision exceeds language,
exceeds speech,
there is more to the text Dante
is saying,
there's more to my experience
of the world than what I can say
in words.
There is--not everything is
reducible or containable within
the syllables of our language.
"This, to what I saw,
is such that it is enough to
call it little.
O Light Eternal."
Once again, "that alone
abidest us in Thyself,"
a divine that is now caught
within itself and is self
contained.
Look at this,
"In Thyself alone and
knowest Thyself,
and, known to Thyself,
and knowing lovest and smiles
on Thyself."
This is the kind of inner and
closure or circularity of the
divine.
In Italian, I have to read to
you in Italian so you see line
123--line 125 maybe,
O luce etterna che sola in
te sidi.
"Sola,"
only you understand yourself,
t'intendi,
e da te intelletta e intendente
te ami e arridi!
You see how the words keep
repeating and falling on
themselves to convey the idea of
the self-enclosed nature,
now there is something that
always escapes,
a grasp and escapes Dante's.
There's some--for all of the
diffusiveness of God in the
creation there is an element of
the divine that literally is
absolutely self-transcendent,
just transcends itself
completely.
"That circling which,
thus begotten,
appeared in Thee as reflected
light when my eyes dwelt on it
for a time,
seemed to me,
within it and in its own
colour,
painted with our likeness."
He sees our own,
as he calls it,
our effigy line 131,
"nostra
affige,"
our likeness.
He doesn't say "my
likeness,"
it's a poem therefore that at
the end seems to want to
retrieve the commonality of the
common likeness that we have.
What he sees is the
incarnation, the human image
within God,
because in God there is also
the human since we are--
if you agree with the principle
that we are creations of God and
the way we were created in His
image,
so therefore there's something
human also within the divine,
and then he continues,
"Like the geometer who
sets all his mind to the
squaring of the circle,"
a famous mathematical surd in
the Middle Ages,
meaning one of the impossible
paradoxes of how do you square
the circle,
and the geometers will go on
reflecting on it and that's what
Dante--
where Dante places himself.
The science of measurement
stumbles against this paradox
that the geometer--and fails.
"Like the geometer who
sets all his mind to the
squaring of the circle and for
all his thinking does not
discover the principle he needs,
such was I at a strange sight.
I wished to see how the image
was fitted to the circle and how
it has its place there;
but my own wings,"
the flight of the soul,
the wings of the soul,
the platonic idea that we go on
developing wings,
of the two Eros allows us to
unfold our wings for the sight.
It's also a pun,
I think, on Dante's own name.
We have been talking about,
"were not sufficient for
that, had not my mind been
smitten by a flash wherein came
its wish.
Here power failed the high
phantasy."
How many fantasies are there?
There are three,
the highest form of the
imagination,
that's what he means that
the--a pretty romantic
distinction,
I mean, coloriage between
imagination and fantasy.
Dante follows--Dante belongs in
that same line of thinking,
"But now my desire and
will,
like a wheel that spins with
even motion,
were revolved by the Love that
moves the sun and the other
stars."
That's the end of the poem
which ends exactly the way--with
Dante doing two things.
One seeing the Prime Mover and
understanding the Prime Mover,
not the way he did at the
beginning of Paradiso I,
but love.
The definition of God as the
Prime Mover,
you remember,
seemed to have a limitation for
Dante as the Prime Mover moves
the universe,
and somehow then detaches,
disengages himself from it.
Now Dante sees that primal,
the motion as a motion of love,
the universe as a universe of
love,
but calls the world together
and prevents it from falling
apart is exactly this power.
Prevents it from chaos,
it's this power called love so
the whole universe is in motion.
Love that moves the sun and the
other stars, and the only thing
stable, the only thing that
makes it cohere is this love.
By using this same language
here of love that moves the sun
and the other stars,
it's a universe of love,
we understand that.
Dante uses, symmetrically,
the same phrase,
the stars of the sun and the
other stars in Inferno--
at the end of Inferno
and at the end of
Purgatorio.
Fair, remember that,
and then now I was cleansed
enough to come back and look at
the stars, the end of
Purgatorio.
Then now Virgil and I finally
managed to come back and see the
stars.
Now Dante says,
the love that moves the sun and
the other stars,
what he's really doing is
placing himself immediately with
this line right back on earth.
He's here with us looking up at
the stars.
It's the line that shifts,
allows him to shift from the
moment of this vision that he
has, a vision that is the vision
of the incarnation at the end.
That is to say his own--our own
likeness, that's all he sees,
that's all he remembers,
and then comes back to earth.
But it also means that this
line places Dante exactly in
Inferno I and this is the
story of the poem.
The story of the poem--we have
been reading the poem as an
account of an experience of a
pilgrim who goes from the dark
wood in Inferno I to the
beatific vision,
whatever he remembers of it,
and then comes back to tell us
about it.
But in effect we are also
discovering in this reading of
the poem,
is that by the end of the poem
Dante says,
now my journey starts,
the real journey was this poem
here.
We are in a sense,
by that last line,
caught in the circle of Dante's
telling, in the drama of Dante's
story.
We read the poem which is a
kind of journey for us,
then we read because we want to
tell our own story,
and then we want to go on
re-reading it once again.
Do you see what I mean?
It's a sort of,
if you wish,
witty even, way for Dante to
say this poem will hold you,
and it's meant to hold you,
and I wish it holds you.
You can see the poem as both a
journey and the telling of the
journey endlessly like the
movement of the sun and the
other stars.
This is the end of the poem.
Let me see, I'm sure that there
are questions.
I raised some issues and we
have a minute--a few minutes and
I'll tell you then later what
we're going to do next time.
Please.
Student:  Can you talk
about this line where he's--
at line 52 [Canto XXXIII],
"Bernard signed to me with
a smile to look
upward…the lofty light
which in itself is true.
There are few things going on
here about light and truth and
I'm wondering--
the light seems to be pure all
and what's happening is that
Dante's vision becomes--
that the faculty improves
enough to appreciate this and
that his sight somehow fails and
then he has failure of memory.
I don't know,
light is the truth,
it no longer illuminates but
isn't very obvious to the truth
at this point.
I'm not sure it seemed like
there was a lot going on and I'm
not quite--
Prof: Okay,
the question is in reference to
lines--
line 52 of Paradiso
XXXIII where Dante says,
"And I who was drawing
near to the end of all
desires,"
that we understand,
" ended perforce the
ardour of my craving.
Bernard signed to me with a
smile to look upward,
but already of myself I was
doing what he wished;"
that's fairly,
at least literally clear,
"for my sight,
becoming pure,"
that's also clear,
Dante's experience in the final
poems can be reduced to a
refinement of the faculty of
vision,
physical but also clearly
spiritual.
"Becoming pure was
entering more and more through
the beam of the lofty light
which in itself is true"
meaning that--
I think this means,
and this is also a footnote of
yours,
it's the footnote is too the
famous phrase,
"In thy light we see the
light."
The idea that--you are quite
right that it's not a light that
reveals an object being a true
object;
that's really what you--the
point that you are making.
That's absolutely true,
I would agree with that,
but it's really a statement
about the light which in itself
is--contains a light.
It's this kind of--that's the
meaning of the biblical phrase,
"In thy light we see the
light," it's not because of
your light I see the world,
I see myself or whatever,
in thy light I see the light.
The light is the light of
truth, that's what he's saying.
It's the light of truth in and
of itself, the light of truth.
Yes, it's a light in itself.
That was your point or not?
Student:  Kind of,
I'm just a little confused what
the function of light is.
Prof: What the function
of light here?
Well, the--I can give you a
little bit of the idea of what
we call the metaphysics of light
in Paradiso.
Dante begins with the idea that
what we know of the divine is
light,
a light that--the power of
which and the limitation of
which is exactly like the dark
in the sense that the light
reveals to us the divine,
but at the same time hides the
origin of the light.
You cannot see through the
light.
That's really the understanding
of Dante in Paradiso I
saying,
"The glory of Him who
moves all things,"
the glory is an image really
means light.
The light of Him,
who moves all things,
is what I really saw.
Now Dante's seeing the origin
of that light,
that which has remained forever
invisible, exactly the way the
dark has.
You may say that some of our
imagination is that we are in
the dark.
We don't know the origins of
anything;
we don't know the causes that
lie beyond our perceptions.
We don't know the origin of the
dark, we may even go like
mystics believing that the dark
is the image,
is the cover for light.
If there is a dark there must
be a light somewhere else,
in fact that dark may
occasionally be removed.
The worst thing about the
mystical language of the divine
in terms of light is that the
light itself,
which makes all things visible,
remains in and of itself
impenetrable in its origin to
the human eye.
Now Dante sees it,
that's the idea of the true
light, "In thy light we see
the light."
Is that a little--
Student:  The beatific
vision then is not exactly--
Prof: This is not a
beatific vision.
He has seen a moment of light
and the origin of the light,
that's still not God.
The beatific--the only thing
that he remembers of the
beatific vision is some--he
doesn't say.
Some sweetness that has
gathered in his heart,
and what he then sees beyond
the general form,
he sees a number of things.
The general form of the cosmos,
which is this conjunction of
circle and square,
book and volume,
if you want to visualize it in
terms of--
I like that image because it
really implies the Word.
It's the theology of the Word
that seems to come out of that.
Then the other things that he
sees is our likeness,
i.e., he sends us back to
Genesis 1, or the creation of
man as told in Genesis.
"Let me us make man in our
image and likeness,"
so here's our likeness.
You are talking now about the
light and the meaning about this
light is that the light--what
does it mean to say that the
light is true?
Not because he reveals and
dissipates the shadows that
would be one way,
one function of the light,
the like the light,
the light of the mind,
the light of the sun,
whatever.
Because of that,
the artificial light,
but there is a way in which
Dante is now thinking about what
is called metaphysics of light.
What is the light in and of
itself?
The light--Dante by the way,
if you really want to know
this,
Dante distinguishes between the
word for light and the word for
lamp,
lume,
luce,
and so on light,
lamp and so on and a number of
scientific distinctions.
Here he is talking about the
vision of the origin of light,
"In thy light we see the
light," that's the meaning
of the phrase.